das Thema was mich sehr bewegt und das
schon seit langem sind die
klimaaktivisten es ist gut wenn junge
Menschen für ihre Überzeugung eintreten
aber der klimaaktivismus in diesem Land
geht für meinen Geschmack zu weit jetzt
hat eine Klima Chaotin gar Kartoffelbrei
auf das Gemälde holzschober des
französischen Impressionisten Claude
Monet geworfen sie können sich diese
dreiste Kartoffelbrei Aktion nicht
vorstellen ich konnte es auch nicht
schauen wir es uns mal an
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo
[Musik]
sie kommen Menschen hungern Mensch
frieren Menschen sterben wir sind in
einer Klimakatastrophe
und alles wovor ihr Angst habt sind
Tomatensuppe oder Kartoffelbrei in einem
Gemälde man muss sich das jetzt hier
wirklich einmal vor Augen führen also
sie waren vor Hunger und wirft mit
Kartoffelbrei das ist nicht nur sinnlos
sondern auch dämlich und noch dazu
kriminell ist auch nicht das erste Mal
die klimaaktivistin die Sie gerade
gesehen haben heißt Mirjam Herrmann und
hat sich auch schon von einer
Autobahnbrücke bei München
beispielsweise abgesagt jetzt drohen ihr
bis zu vier Jahren Haft und das führt
mich zu meiner ersten Frage an Frau
Wagner
empfinden sie solche haben sie sich
gedacht vermutlich empfinden sie solche
Klima Kleber als Kriminelle ich glaube
das haben wir ja schon im in dem Video
gehört wenn man den Vergleich einfach
bezieht wofür wir uns einsetzen wofür
wir kämpfen wogegen wir kämpfen ist ein
beschädigtes Gemälde einfach nicht im
Vergleich und da ist Kriminalität würde
ich also natürlich ist es nicht im
legalen Bereichen Gemälde zu beschädigen
aber als kriminell das zu bezeichnen
wenn wir uns schauen wofür wäre und für
gegenbekämpfen das ist ja nicht an
irgendein Gemälde das ist ein Gemälde
von Monet das ist Kunst das ist 100
Millionen Euro wert das ist Kultur das
heißt sie würden sagen für ihre Ziele
ist es völlig in Ordnung wenn Sie ein
Kunstwerk mutwillig beschädigen in dem
Fall wurde glücklicherweise nichts
beschädigt es war eine eine eine Wand
davor aber sie würden so weit gehen und
sagen sie finden das ist in Ordnung also
ich werde niemanden der mit mir auf
meiner Seite auf meiner Seite kämpft in
den Schlamm oder die Tomatensuppe ziehen
wie gesagt wenn wir uns anschauen was
auf der anderen Seite für Zerstörungen
passiert Menschen verlieren ihr Leben
ganze Kultur und werden zerstört indigen
Menschen werden von ihren Ländern
vertrieben dann sehen wir jetzt einmal
was das in uns an macht wenn unsere
Kultur angegriffen wird und das ist
genau das was wir in anderen Ländern
auch machen in dem Sinne finde ich das
eigentlich ein ganz provokativer Moment
um zu zeigen was was tut es eigentlich
wenn Kultur unsere das was uns wichtig
ist beschädigt wird und das ist in einem
lebensbedrohlichen
Umfang was gerade in anderen Dominik
Kartoffelbrei gegen Hunger werfen finden
Sie auch sinnvoll das finde ich
interessanten Punkt er war mir noch gar
nicht aufgefallen und nicht damit nerven
das habe ich zu Hause beigebracht
bekommen auch wegen Hunger auf der Welt
aufessen oder auch das Essen würdigen
und mit Kartoffelbrei werfen gegen den
Hunger das habe ich nicht ganz
verstanden du hast eine gute Frage das
müssen sie dann deaktivieren selber
vielleicht fragen was sie sich dabei
gedacht haben aber da verstehen sie mein
Gedanke den verstehe ich total leer okay
Herr Bolz was sagen sie denn sind diese
klimaaktivisten kriminelle oder nicht
ich meine es gibt Gesetze die das
sichert was da geschehen ist erfassen
und die müsste man einfach nur anwenden
und dann ist die Sache auch wieder in
Ordnung also ich persönlich sehe dass
doch als eine recht infantile Aktion und
das ist für mich auch nicht das
eigentliche Problem
junge Leute sind so drauf die wollen
protestieren das ging unserer Generation
genauso und das wird sich immer wieder
wiederholen die entscheidende Frage ist
eine vollkommen andere nämlich wäre
reagiert die Gesellschaft darauf und das
macht mir Sorgen denn es gibt einen
nicht nur mittlerweile Klamm heimliches
sondern auch offene Sympathie für diese
Aktionen auch gerade auch die
autobahnkleberei und ähnliches mehr und
zwar in den Medien in sehr sehr vielen
Medien und leider Gottes auch in der
Politik selbst und da scheint mir der
eigentliche Haken des ganzen Themas zu
sein dass im Grunde eine bestimmte
Politik das ist im Wesentlichen die
Politik der Grünen aber auch der
radikalen Linken Seite der SPD dass
diese Politik die eigentliche eine
parlamentarische Politik sein müsste und
die sogar Regierungsverantwortung hat
dass diese Politik sich Nebenschauplätze
produzieren lässt von
ja wirklich zugeordneten NGOs oder
zugeordneten Jugendbewegungen die genau
dieselbe Politik
vertreten im Grunde wie die Grünen und
die SPD also im Thema Klima Umwelt
insgesamt aber auch in vielen anderen
Themen die dann aber wenn Sie so wollen
zur Regierungspolitik und zur
parlamentarischen Politik noch diese
wunderbaren Zusatz machen außer
parlamentarische Opposition das heißt
die Grünen haben es geschafft
im Parlament zu sein parlamentarisch zu
arbeiten in die Regierung zu kommen und
außer parlamentarisch zu kämpfen und das
haben die Grünen übrigens auch
angekündigt wenn man wie ich ein
fleißiger Fernsehzuschauer ist dann kann
man sich erinnern dass sie gesagt haben
wir wollen jetzt für unsere Politik für
die Klimapolitik wir wollen alles
aktivieren auch außerhalb des Parlaments
und da ist für mich liegt für mich das
eigentliche Problem also nicht die
Jugendlichen die tolle Ideen haben und
irgendwelche Verrücktheiten in die Welt
setzen und dafür gerade stehen 25
spät erst erwachsen also eigentlich erst
wenn meine Familie gründet und die
meisten sind mit 40 noch nicht erwachsen
deshalb ist es ja auch so fatal dass man
daran denkt das Wahlalter noch weiter
herabzusenken also Erwachsenheit leider
Gottes ein sehr späte Entwicklung aber
wie gesagt das entscheidende sind nicht
die Jugendlichen die die das machen
sondern das ist die Reaktion der Politik
und der Medien darauf und die halte ich
wirklich für extrem Bedenken Herr Kraus
würden sie da zustimmen das ist nicht
hier die Jugendlichen selbst also die
25-jährige Frau ist sondern vor allem
die Medienpolitik und Gesellschaft
ich möchte eine andere Beitrag noch dazu
leisten damit eine klar ist einer wie
ich der 22 Abiturjahrgänge zum Abitur
geführt hat ja der hat sich natürlich
auch Gedanken gemacht über das
Engagement von jungen Leuten und ich bin
meine jungen Leuten jetzt sage ich es
mal ein bisschen deftig immer wieder in
den Hintern getreten wenn sie
soletarisch waren gemotzt haben aber es
ist nichts geschehen es sind für
Proteste
ich habe Probleme mit dem Begriff
klimaaktivisten mit dem Begriff
Aktivisten
denn was hier
stattfindet ist für mich erstens ein
Verstoß gegen
Demokratieprinzip
und letztendlich haben Verstoß gegen
strafgesetzbuch
gegen Demokratieprinzip da müsste man
jetzt vielleicht die Rede von Schäuble
zur Eröffnung als Alterspräsident des
Bundestages noch mehr rausgreifen
aufgreifen weil er über das
Demokratieprinzip besprochen hat in
einer Demokratie wird nach Diskussion
Diskussion Diskussion Kompromiss
Kompromiss Kompromiss nach Mehrheit
irgendwas entschieden
das ist Demokratie aber es wird nicht
entschieden weil eine bestimmte Gruppe
oder pressur Group oder NGO es so haben
will das ist ja mein erstes Problem
und zweites Problem weil sie die Frage
gestellt haben kriminelle ja soweit will
ich jetzt nicht greifen aber wir haben
eine Kollision
mit mehreren Paragraphen des
Strafgesetzbuches Hausfriedensbruch
gefährliche Eingriff in den
Straßenverkehr Sachbeschädigung
plastisch machen an dem Kartoffelbrei
Beispiel gehört diese Frau für Sie ins
Gefängnis verurteilt oder nicht es gibt
selbstverständlich hat sie das
Strafgesetz gebrochen ich kenne dich so
auf Prozessordnung nicht es muss eine
Sanktionierung erfolgen und zwar aus dem
einen Grund weil das mit dem Rechtsstand
in Unrechtsbewusstsein der Bevölkerung
zu tun hat und jetzt schlage ich meinen
Bogen zu einem der kürzlich ein halbes
Jahr im Knast saß weil er die Rundfunk
Zwangsgebühren nicht bezahlt hat die 18
Euro pro Monat das muss und wenn man in
der Bevölkerung bekannt ist dass einer
der nicht mal ein Rundfunkgerät zu Hause
hat die 18 Euro nicht bezahlt dann aber
sechs Monate im Knast absitzt und dann
sieht das hier sowas ohne jede Sanktion
vonstatten geht dann ist das ein Knacks
im rechts und Unrechtsbewusstsein der
Bevölkerung wir Fragen hier einmal Herrn
Stöckl
#d Einzel liegen ja auch die Kunst und
die Kultur und hier ist meine Frage was
halten Sie denn davon wenn Kartoffelbrei
und Tomatensuppe auf die Kunst geworfen
wird also ich finde es an sich schwierig
diese Attacken auf Kunstwerke jetzt war
ja auch in London diese Attacke bei
Madame tust so und auf die Figuren und
hier und da und alles was mich daran
viel mehr stört ist dass ich glaube dass
man damit gar nichts erreicht weil ich
glaube erstmal in erster Linie lassen
sich die Politiker nicht erpressen also
es ist ja im Grunde genommen man
versucht ja mit den Attacken auf die
Kunstwerke irgendwie an die Politik
ranzukommen dass die Politik irgendetwas
daran ändert ich glaube dass die
Politiker sich an sich schon nicht
erpressen lassen dürfen sie aber nicht
dürfen sie auch nicht so dass der Punkt
1 Punkt 2 ist glaube ich dass man
überhaupt wenn man jetzt ich meine der
jetzt ist wenn ich es richtig gelesen
habe ist ja eigentlich keinem Gemälde
wirklich was passiert aber es könnte
etwas passieren so ist es so das heißt
wir haben große Kunstwerke die quasi
irreparabel sind wenn Sie also einmal
zerstört sind dann sind sie zerstört und
das weil halt irgendwelche Leute sich
daran
auslassen so auf der anderen Seite bin
ich aber auch so ein bisschen bei dir
weil ich trotzdem auch finde ist es gut
ist dass eine junge Generation etwas
gegen den Klimaschutz macht was mich
halt nur stört ist halt dass dann sollen
sie sich lieber bei Scholz für den Klima
Entschuldigung für den Klimaschutz weil
ich finde ich würde mich als wenn ich
Aktivist wäre würde ich mich eher bei
Scholz am Auto festkleben damit er
endlich mit mir spricht weil ich glaube
halt ein Monet versuchen zu zerstören
bringt halt nichts weil ich meine Scholz
wird jetzt trotzdem irgendwohin fliegen
und was machen und ich meine am Ende
können wir als Gesellschaft ja sowieso
nichts dagegen tun es muss ja von der
Politik auskommen ich bin kein Politiker
sondern ich bin Entertainer das heißt
mein Beruf ist Unterhaltung ich
unterhalte Leute und deswegen fühle ich
mich zum Beispiel auch jetzt nicht dass
ich denke ich möchte jetzt eine
Kartoffelsuppe auf einen Monet schmeißen
sondern ich möchte unterhalten ich
erwarte aber von den Politikern dass sie
quasi dann den klimaaktivisten zuhören
wenn jetzt quasi keiner aus so eine
gewisse so eine gewisse Bonität nach
vorne bringt sagt na ja was sie da
machen will ich gar nicht hören also ich
finde zumindest muss man mit ihnen
sprechen so und scheinbar machen sie es
ja so lange bis einer mit ihnen spricht
also deswegen bin ich der Meinung man
müsste zumindestens mit ihnen sprechen
egal ob der Protest jetzt gefechtfertigt
ist oder psychologisch falsch weil die
Politik dann eher wenn sie sich darauf
aushalten kann zu sagen das ist
kriminell was die machen die Jalousien
runterlassen ja es gibt doch unendlich
viele Möglichkeiten auch für junge Leute
sich zu betätigen man kann zu den
Abgeordneten gehen die noch und noch
besuchen man kann sich diese Länder hat
heute beispielsweise Luisa Neubauer
eingeladen das war heute gerade heute
ein austauschflug Fridays for future und
Christian
728 oder was weiß ich 736 Bundestags
Abgeordneten Landtagsabgeordnete denen
muss man wirklich den Fußabstreifer
heißtreten so ungefähr ja heraus finden
Sie überhaupt dass wir zu wenig machen
was den Klimaschutz betrifft mit Blick
auf den Klimawandel das wird zu wenig
machen also weil wenn man sagt diese
Aktionen sind richtig er muss ja
Deutschland wirklich der absolute
Versager im fachklima sein wenn man sich
das weltweit anschaut sind wir das ja
gar nicht deswegen
Spitzenreiter um den Preis einer die
Industrialisierung dementsprechend die
die Aussage von von ihnen Herrn Stöcke
dementsprechend ist ja ganz klar die
Frage hier ist es überhaupt kurz vor 12
in Deutschland dass solche bornierten
Proteste passieren müssen also ich
glaube schon was sie sagen oder was was
du sagst ist schon richtig ich glaube
wir tun auch mehr als viele andere
Länder also ich habe immer das Gefühl
dass wir in Deutschland so viel für den
Klimawandel also für gegen den
Klimawandel machen und wenn man dann so
betrachtet was das andere Länder das gar
nicht interessiert und die auch im
Grunde genommen überhaupt gar nichts
dagegen tun wollen ich glaube auch das
größte Problem ist dass im Grunde
genommen wir das ja auch
länderübergreift endlich hinkriegen
müssen also ich meine wenn diese großen
Nationen die anderen dieses nicht
interessiert also wenn man so sich an an
so reden von Trump erinnert und so der
sagt na ja Klima weil es gibt als gar
nicht so weiter genau so da denke ich
denn wenn wir nur etwas hier punktuell
tun wird es für den Klimaschutz der
ganzen Welt sowieso nichts bringen das
heißt im Grunde müssen auch die großen
der Welt dazu gehöre ich nicht also ich
kann gar nicht genug machen um etwas zu
verändern und ich finde immer das muss
dann von der hohen also der ganz hohen
Politik ausgehen dass man sich dort
aufeinander zu bewegt weil ansonsten sag
mal wenn wir alles dafür tun und die
Autos weg und und Diesel weg und E-Autos
und alles nur noch diesen das aber wenn
alle anderen sagen naja ist sozusagen
egal lass doch mal die deutschen das
machen das habe ich auch ein großes
Problem
bitte berichten Sie mich ein falsches
sie verzichten auf Fleisch verzichten
auf Flugreisen und sie haben heute Abend
auch die These mitgebracht warum es
gerade wichtig ist die wollen wir uns
auch gerne anhören